foreign
let's go out to San Antonio Texas and
talk to Kendra what's up Kendra
can I be here how are you I'm partying
we are doing great so what's up how can
I help
I have a question about how to deal with
survivor's guilt ooh what happened
so I am a channel on the Asus score holy
smokes my I came from a very very
abusive childhood my mother had a severe
drug problem okay
um
it's myself and three other siblings and
I am are you the one that made it
yes I am 8 618 days sober
congratulations wow
Kendra
that's amazing
but it's hard knowing that I am the only
one minute survived I know
are your brothers and sisters still
alive and hurting
uh they are not
um
my sister Melissa
odina 99 my brother Josh OD'd in 2001.
um I have another brother that OD'd in
2014. good God almighty
you guys lived in hell didn't you we did
what was your path out
determination
determined
um
when I was 15 I got pregnant with my son
Luke
um my son ended up I ended up being shot
when my son was six people it went
through my leg killed my son
um that's when I wrote my sobriety
because literally the day that my son
died I wanted to die yeah
um
I had a very very
lovely woman his grandmother who
said not on my watch it's not gonna go
down like this
um and she literally held me hostage for
three days to get me clean again
oh because you're you were heading out
huh I was I was done yeah
I've been sober ever since she had a
massive stroke about two years after I
got clean
and I have
pretty much any time I remotely think
their life's not going the way it needs
to
I hear that woman at the rest of my head
she's your guardian angel isn't she
you may have heard you may have heard me
say this on the show but
um
okay
there's a great conversation years ago
with somebody who'd been to parts of the
world where there was just Mass
Slaughter of people and they asked a
pastor there how do you still believe in
God with all of this death and
destruction
um
and Where's God in all this and the
pastor looked at him kind of cold and
said oh I stopped asking Where's God a
long time ago I started asking where's
God's people when did they show up
and I don't know if this person was
religious or not but this is one of
those holy moments when somebody
saw you and took you and said not on my
watch
he was he was definitely religious she
was the most devout Catholic southern
New Orleans woman you would ever meet in
your life that's one of my favorite
people in the world to be around
because they can out cook you and out
swear ya and out Bible yet all at the
same time the people are amazing
exactly
all right so
what happened so that you're talking
you have experienced and seen can I
how whole are you right now can I be
pretty specific for our listening
audience
um
I don't want to melt you here on this
call but I want I want them to to have
some sort of picture about what you've
experienced
I have no phone case I have a seven
month old grandbaby I
um can work in 90 hours a week so like
trying to
be out of debt and change my
generational
drama
um
but I'm not working I am trying to be
working
like I am burying myself
and working because if I'm not working
my mind goes I don't deserve okay
you don't deserve this beautiful healthy
grandbaby
you don't deserve two grown kids that
have turned into relatively all right
adults are they relatively all right
adults
I have one that graduated two years
early I have another one that graduated
with honors I I I don't know as a single
mom how I ended up having
so amazing
kids I'll tell you
you want to hear it
what's one of my core principles on this
show
I will never lie to you
I'll tell you exactly how two amazing
kids made their way into the world and
grew into two amazing functional adults
because they had a gangster of a mom
foreign
and that doesn't mean that Mom didn't
need somebody to grab her by the hair
and keep her alive for three days
and she held her baby boy she bled out
right in front of her
that doesn't mean you didn't need help
along the way
and that doesn't mean you got real lucky
sometimes
but it does mean
that they had a mama that changed their
family tree
I'm definitely trying no no no honey
you clawed through concrete to create a
new path for those kids and you did
here's the ugly thing about survivor's
guilt tell me if I'm if I'm on to
something okay
there's usually I call it the haunting
there's a couple of things that haunt
people with Survivor skill the first
thing is I should have or I could have
should have gone back for brother and
sister I could have gone back and done
this if I had just done this or if I had
just done that is that there every day
okay that's number one
it is absolutely Stone not true
okay
you have escaped a
nuclear reaction and the Temptation is
to go make yourself into the hero that
could have walked through radiation and
all of the blast fall out to rescue
people and that simply you could you
couldn't have done it it's not true
that's number one
number two you're haunted by being on
the outside of your tribe and this
sounds crazy to people who hear your
story they're like you have an Aces
score a freaking 10.
like
that means you literally lived in hell
and
every loved one you have around you has
died
and
it doesn't make sense but you left your
tribe in order to survive and there's a
part of you that says but those are my
people
Fair
People Like Us don't sleep through the
night and hold healthy grandbabies
People Like Us don't work 90 hours a
week we just get checks in the mail
People Like Us have to steal the last
two and a half weeks of the month
because we smoked the other half or we
snorted the other half or we pulled out
the other half
Fair
very fair
so sometimes survivor's guilt is a proxy
pain
for
disconnection from what feels like our
roots
because of those kind of people are the
ones that have Healthy Families we are
the kind that burn this thing to the
ground
and the third one is the haunting is the
question that is is the worst one I
think because it has no answer
and that is why me
like how in the hell did I get out
why did I get picked well I gotta carry
all this stuff
absolutely and why does every day
feel like I have to fight for it
so let me um paint you a different
picture with that question why me I I
understand that question intellectually
and I understand that question in my
soul
but I have to be honest I gotta own
reality that there is not an answer to
that question that I'll have on this
side of being alive
if my faith believes her right maybe
I'll get an answer to that on the other
side but I ain't gonna get that here
the question that's more important is
what am I gonna do now
what am I gonna do with this gift
I don't know why I got it I don't even
want it and it's hard to carry
it's real real heavy because inside this
gift also is
The Haunting of my brother and my sister
and my baby boy and my mom even my dad
my dad was evil but even my dad
they're all in this thing and this
sucker's heavy to carry around right
you still there
I am okay
every day I have to
choose happiness
and sometimes it's harder than others I
got you
and then when I come up on birthdays or
anniversaries or
that's when it's hardest
because how come I get another birthday
and they don't
so can I give you permission just to be
real sad on those days
here's what I'd love for you to do I'd
love for you to write them a birthday
card and read it to them on every
birthday and every anniversary
or write them a letter
about all the cool stuff they're missing
and let them know how much you miss them
and let them know how pissed off you are
that they're not here
let them know all of it
how cool this little grandbaby is
if you feel that sense of guilt and that
sense of sadness and sense of
broken-heartedness that they're not with
you they didn't get out to
and you run from it
that fire will eventually overtake you
to
but if you will turn and walk directly
back through that fire you're gonna find
out it's not burning anymore
and you're gonna find out the ghosts of
your brothers and your sisters and your
baby
are still there and you can write them
letters and you can tell them I miss you
and you can tell them I'm living my best
damn life for you
and what you're going to find is in five
years and seven years
you're gonna accidentally forget one of
those birthdays not because you're bad
not because you're you have no character
and you can't believe you forgot
because your body has finally let them
go
they can finally go rest
because right now you're dragging them
around right
every day yeah
it's time for them to go
time for him to go and I know that's not
an easy thing it's going to take some
time
but I do think it's worth your time
writing them a letter and every time
your son's birthday comes around
you let your family know mama's gonna be
sad today
I'm not gonna do anything destructive
I'm not gonna hurt myself I'm not going
to use again
but I am going to write my son a letter
I'm gonna take myself out to some sort
of meal by myself
or I'm gonna throw a party imma do
whatever you want to do
other boy's gonna be part of you for the
rest of your life
we gotta stop asking the why me question
and we got to start asking with a smile
on our face and some Adventure in our
heart what am I gonna do now
how am I going to
live the funnest most adventurous most
beautiful Reckless
generous life I can
because they didn't get to
that makes sense
instead of it being something that
weighs you down it becomes jet fuel and
what comes next how old are you
you're a 44 year old grandma good gravy
Kendra you're not even halfway done yet
the Kendra party's just getting going
have you gone to see a counselor
um
[Music]
I've been in a counseling for the last
20 years
are you done with it
with counseling no okay
I just put it on pause because I'm
trying to pass my house because nobody
in four generations has ever owned a
house how close are you
38 thousand dollars
until your house is paid off so my house
is paid off I will be completely dead
free and thirty eight thousand dollars
how long is that going to take you I
know you already have that date circle
on your calendar how close are you
three years and two days
if I don't die of exhausted
I I I Can't Describe to you how amazing
you are
and I know that doesn't make you feel
better and that doesn't take away what
happened to you and your little girl and
doesn't take away your lost baby boy and
those images in your mind I know
but there's that great Terry real quote
that I just love
which is
the family trauma rolls downhill like a
forest fire generation to generation
until one brave soul turns and stares it
down and says this stops with me
and it brings peace and laughter and joy
to Great grandkids that you will never
meet
it also means that the person that stops
and stares down a roaring forest fire
gets burned and scarred along the way
and that's the position you've chosen
and generations will tell the story of
Grandma Kendra
because she said no more
she said no more
the healing path out if I'm if you're my
sister or if you're like sitting down
having dinner with me here's what I
would tell you
you gotta systematically start writing
these folks letters that you lost
and let them know how you're doing
and it's different than praying it out
or just speaking it out when you're
mumbling around the house or when you're
outside in the backyard having a
cigarette you got to be able to write it
down and get out of your body okay even
if you don't spell well if you're if
your handwriting's off I don't care any
of that stuff
but I want you to get a nice notebook
and write it down
in the next birthday that comes up of
somebody that you've lost I want you to
go to the store and buy a birthday card
spend the four bucks on it I know you're
trying to pay off that do it anyway
spend the money on it and
I want you to have some sort of private
ceremony for them okay and then the last
thing is you got to got to got to
get on the phone they're in San Antonio
I know there's some incredible providers
there in the state of Texas because I I
know them personally
and I want you to get on and and go find
a trauma counselor in your area
and say I'm ready to fully set this
childhood down
set it down and they might get with a
medical provider because you might need
some the aces stuff there's there's
medical complications that come with an
Aces score of a 10 just over a lifetime
heart issues and blood pressure all that
kind of stuff so I think sitting down
with the doctor and saying hey I'm gonna
slow down my
uh maybe this is a good example so if
you're watching
um NASCAR
and they're hammering it on that
straightaway and they're going 250 miles
an hour however fast they go I don't
know how fast they go and they start to
make a turn they have to slow down to
make that turn
so that they can stay in the race and
get to the next straightaway and Hammer
it again
I want you to think of the next couple
of months going to see a doctor going to
see a trauma counselor it's going to
cost you money you have to slow down you
have to miss a couple of shifts and it's
going to slow down your progress what
you're doing is making a turn because if
you just keep going this hard in three
years you're gonna have a paid for house
and you'll be dead on the front porch
and that I don't want that for you I
want you to pay this house off you're
gonna be 50 years old you're gonna have
the house paid off and once you sit on
that front porch being a crazy grandma
Kendra to those grandkids
and letting your your grown kids go have
hot dates with their
husbands and wives or whatever is going
on in your world
but I want you to slow down for just a
minute and make that turn you're going
to find out that when you make that turn
and you get healthy both
emotionally and psychologically and
physically it's gonna make those
straightaways even faster than you can
imagine
it's gonna feel like you're slowing down
and you're stopping but it's not it's
just re-gearing okay it's just making
the turn
just being smart and being safe so that
you can hit it on the way out
talk to a lot of brave people it's my
job I talk to a lot of courageous people
a lot of people are making some turns
and you my friend Kendra are at the very
very very top of that list I'm so so
proud of you
if I can help you in any way holler at
me okay
I'll be with you every step of the way
when you pay that house off
um you're giving us a call back because
you're gonna do that debt free scream
and we're gonna you're gonna hear me
cheering all the way from Nashville
Tennessee
thank you love